how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and of course
everything relating to the mcu and we
have some really big
mcu news that came out today now a few
months ago disney had their financial
earnings call we were pretty hopeful
that we were going to be getting some
mcu news about some of the disney plus
series or about black widow or the
eternals
unfortunately we didn't really get any
news at all the only thing that we
really got was the fact that disney plus
was coming out with what they call
premiere access their video on demand
service in which mulan came out on
so pretty disappointing but disney did
go on to say
that they're going to be having an
investor's day soon and they would talk
more about the upcoming marvel disney
plus shows
well the date of their investor's day
has finally been revealed and we'll talk
about what this means
in this video but first if you're new
and you love the mcu be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest news
so the investors day is going to be held
on and is going to be webcast
on october 7th of 2020 this year
so less than a month away and it's going
to be held at 10 a.m
ast this information comes from the live
storm
event page which is where last year's
investors day webcast from so although
nothing is confirmed
or set in stone many of us are expecting
some pretty big news or at least
updates for marvel for example last
year's investors day we got some pretty
big news
for example last year we got official
confirmation of the falcon and the
winter soldier series the one division
series
the loki series and marvel's what if
series along with some star wars news as
well
so huge huge reveals from disney at this
event last year
and if you combine that with the fact
that disney actually told us they would
talk
more about the upcoming disney plus
shows and the investor day
this year we should definitely be paying
attention to this year's investors day
so again it's not officially confirmed
but everybody is very hopeful that we're
going to get some pretty big news in
regards to marvel and the mcu
we know that they're definitely going to
be talking about marvel and they're
definitely going to be giving us some
updates but we're hopeful that we're
going to get a major bomb dropped at one
point in time
fortunately we don't have that much
longer to wait it's less than a month
away
so as we get closer to the event i'll be
sure to do another video for those of
you who would like to watch it i'll
explain exactly how you can
and if we get any more updates on what
we can expect i'll definitely be sure to
let everybody know
but in the midst of this pandemic and
everything kind of shifting around right
now let me know what you would like to
hear
from the investors day from disney and
for marvel let me know your thoughts in
the comments down below don't forget to
like the video and subscribe so you stay
up to date on all the latest mcu news
and so you can enter this week's
giveaway for a chance to win a thanos
funko pop i'm picking a winner on monday
don't forget to follow me on instagram
and twitter for more giveaways and live
updates and as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof
you